لقد أمضى الرئيس الروسي
ثماني سنوات في محاولة لبناء
الميزانية العمومية الحصينة لهذا الاقتصاد المحصن
بينما يمكنه الانطلاق في غزوه لأوكرانيا
ويكون آمنًا في المنزل في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، وقد قطع الغرب ذلك
وشل ذلك الاقتصاد الحصين
الأسواق العالمية يمكنك  ترى
أوروبا قد فتحت على انخفاض حاد هنا ،
هذا يتبع حقًا انتعاش حاشد
يوم الجمعة ، لذا لن
أعير الكثير من الاهتمام هناك لآسيا ، لكن
انظر إلى العقود الآجلة لنا ، سترى
يومًا صعبًا ، إنه تداعيات
العزلة  هذا المنتج الضخم للطاقة
، صحيح وما يمكن أن يحدث مع
النظام المصرفي في جميع أنحاء العالم
وأنت تحاول عزل البنوك الروسية
عن النظام.
قصة التضخم العالمية
، ها هي بورصة الأوراق المالية الروسية مغلقة الآن لسبب إغلاق البنك المركزي وروسيا لها لأنها ستفتح بشكل كبير وستكون كذلك  أكون هنا أو هنا
وانظر وقد تم
فرض عقوبات على البنك المركزي من قبل الاتحاد الأوروبي والولايات المتحدة
أعني أن هذا يشل بشكل أساسي
قدرة البلاد على
تمويل هذه الحرب وهو بالضبط
ما يريد الأوروبيون والأمريكيون
القيام به ليس فقط  طاقة في
قصة 401k الخاصة بك وكذلك هذا أه
حول إمدادات الطاقة إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
إنها قصة جيوسياسية ضخمة متشابكة
هناك وكل هذه السلع من
روسيا ومن أوكرانيا بالمناسبة
كل هذا يمكن أن يغذي ذلك
التضخم العالمي  القصة التي تحدثنا عنها ،
لدينا سلاسل توريد ستكون
أكثر تعقيدًا ولدينا أسئلة حول
كيف سيتمكن المشترون الأوروبيون والغربيون من
دفع ثمنها إذا كان
العالم سيعزل فلاديمير بوتين
وإذا كان الاقتصاد الروسي يعاني من حالة
من الذعر فهو على حافة
الانهيار المالي على المدى القريب هنا